it was something that popped in your
book that was so because everybody
I've talked to so many comedians uh on
either on late night but especially on
this show and they talk about these
early jobs they've had
and
because people have had some really
crazy jobs but you had one that you talk
about in the book where it's it's early
you're trying to get into Show Business
it hasn't quite gelled in stand up yet
and you get this gig doing some kind of
a Star Trek show Deep Space Nine Deep
Space Nine but it's a live show that you
did at a mall
and okay Paramount had a subsidiary
named uh Paramount Park so I'm sure has
been dissolved uh and a man named Stan
ran it and um it's always a stand
would tell us about fantastic new gigs
uh we're doing a Jack In The Box
promotion uh do you and a Klingon want
to go out and
um we drive out to Pomona and uh uh
stand around saying things like
greetings majorly Lanka of the planet
bonjour and
get the away from me so you had to
memorize you had to memorize all this
stuff
oh I it was I am can sometimes be
half-assed when it comes to certain jobs
so stand up or really care about but
that one I I know I could have gone deep
into the bijorn uh history and uh Star
Trek itself I did not are you in makeup
and stuff too yes I don't know this is
my genetic makeup do you speak of oh
spirit gum
oh so you had to if any kid said to you
hey nice mask you'd have to say mask of
what do you speak Earth creature that
kind of stuff yes oh yes well that's
what I did no one told me did you do it
did you go oh did you go
and what is the uh and you go in the
book you talk about going off script a
bit yeah yeah which was really funny
well because the I did read a little bit
about the assurance and it turned out
they were kind of what I felt like it
was sort of the World War II Jewish
experience of that Realm and so um and
this is sci-fi yeah it's not real but
you decided to go deep into that and
then bring that to the mall and tell
kids about it is that correct my parents
the last I saw from them I was in the
Attic of my parents house yes we had
houses
we we're not animals oh you have a
wrinkly face we are not so different to
you and I and I I was playing with my
paper dolls and yet all I have left is
my parents is this bloody paper doll I
heard the scream you were saying this to
kids at a mall listen
hey lady I just want some Jollibee yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I got I got a 45
minute shift
I gotta keep their attention we're in
the oh that would have my attention
anything
oh oh you think I should be with a
Ferengi because you'd like to see what
would come out from us what
what child you would have
hey Sona think of all the amazing things
in life that are expressions of just you
yeah I mean like the chocolate that you
had on your face when you came in
because you just ate that what was it
you were eating I was eating a giant
cookie giant cookie yeah and that's so
Sona okay or that song you stream over
and over again it's just so you what's
that song For You Twinkle Twinkle Little
Star yeah but it's for my boys I know
still it's nice okay or you know that
podcast that comedy podcast you just
gotta listen to yeah Conan O'Brien needs
a friend is that what you listen to in
your spare time yeah I love it
everything that makes you you
difference State Farm believes Insurance
should work the same way your plan your
coverage selections could be
personalized by you and only you that's
cool I shouldn't shout but this is how
strongly I feel about it you go to
choose the plan you want by picking the
options to fit you like choosing to
bundle your home and auto policies is
what the State Farm personal price plan
is all about getting the coverage you
want at an affordable price just for you
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state options
selected by customers availability and
eligibility may vary think of all the
emotional damage you did think of all
the kids out there right now that are
going to be stand-ups and write books
like yours because they went to the mall
one day well there's a fun alien how
dare you look at me
I was molested by a girl
nine tentacles it was
yes even though I felt a little pleasure
that pleasure oh wait a minute well you
kind of liked it confusion of the trauma
is that you can't feel the shame
we've got to get this to the Star Trek
people yeah this is good stuff
very good stuff no but I I want to
acknowledge that uh the Star Trek it is
a it is a real world and I did not mean
to poop on it well I don't think you did
hey okay I think it's not like when you
do a show you have to acknowledge the
the native land that you're in it's fair
games no you do with Star Trek you
continue to acknowledge this was all
taken from Gene Roddenberry